[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 3 septembre
bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 les titres de cette
édition d'information
la visite ce matin ce cet après-midi de
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre désormais à saint-cyr-l'ecole
geneviève darrieussecq et est
aujourd'hui au lycée militaire pour la
rentrée et déplacement quelques mois
après la révélation des affaires de
harcèlement dans l'établissement où on
est le nettoiement de la décharge
sauvage de carrières sous poissy un
comité de pilotage et un projets ont
émergé sur le sujet mais une association
dénonce de son côté l'inaction de la
mairie et de la préfecture son président
est notre invité est les vacances
terminées nous parlerons du bilan
estival du tourisme en ile de france une
tendance plutôt positive et le château
de versailles toujours comme vitrine du
secteur dans les yvelines est le détail
dans ce journal en plateau également
tout à l'heure le champion du monde de
house dance
il est yvelinois est la rentrée se
poursuit dans le département plus de
trois cent cinq mille élèves sont
revenus hier sur les bancs de l'école et
le directeur académique
antoine destrés en parler sur ce plateau
quelques derniers ajustements de la
carte scolaire ont été effectués en
cette première journée
à noter et 19 ouvertures de classes dans
le département quelques exemples à la
maternelle et de la commanderie à
elancourt de paul verlaine à montigny le
bretonneux ou encore halle élémentaire
jules-ferry de sartrouville la direction
académique en revanche est décidé de la
fermeture de cette classe du territoire
la liste qui va peut-être sa fiche et la
voici donc pour ces fermetures c'est le
cas à l'école élémentaire louis clément
abus que jean rostand et les marolles à
chatou ou encore pour l'établissement
maternelle montebello à maisons laffitte
et petits couacs en cette rentrée 249
lycéens et et hier matin sans
affectation une solution a été trouvée
pour les 60 élèves de seconde dans ce
cas pour le reste une commission
d'ajustement doit se tenir jeudi
retrouvez des établissements l éducation
nationale des yvelines indique tout de
même que la situation concerne à moitié
moins de jeunes que l'an passé
[Musique]
le lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
a fait sa rentrée à des classes
aujourd'hui pour l'occasion geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées s'est rendu dans
l'établissement et visite sous fonds
d'investissement financier mais aussi
sur la question de la prévention en
suite à une affaire d'harcèlement qui a
été révélé en 2018 patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry était sur
place la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des armées geneviève
darrieussecq est arrivé ici au lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école aux
alentours de 15 heures
elle a rencontré des élèves et des
enseignants du bts cyberdéfense une
formation à la sécurité des réseaux
informatiques et aux systèmes embarqués
un cursus créé en 2010 cette norme est
investi dans ce bts pour pouvoir remplir
les rangs de techniciens spécialisés
dans le cyber dans leur armée donc on
est formés dans le domaine de la cyber
défense va acquérir
comment bien sécurisé des réseaux
informatiques par exemple s'ils ont bien
protégé notre ordinateur donc voir des
programmations
ensuite on a du réseau si elle a aussi
du système donc on va vraiment où on a
des compétences du bol dans tous les
domaines la secrétaire d'état a aussi
évoqué le plan d'investissement de 100
millions d'euros destinée à la
rénovation des lycées militaires
elle a aussi évoqué les questions de
discriminations et de harcèlement
sexiste dans ces établissements
il faut écouter il faut regarder il faut
dépister faut voir les signaux faibles
bien sûr les signaux forts et faire en
sorte de pouvoir prévenir et faire en
sorte surtout s'il y avait le moindre
problème de pouvoir sanctionner
rapidement et bien nous arriverons à
faire en sorte que ces comportement
d'une minorité qui sont inacceptables ne
se reproduise pas près de 800 élèves ont
fait leur rentrée 2019 2020
au lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
des étudiants répartis entre le lycée le
bts et les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles de l'armée
la rentrée universitaire l approche
notamment pour les étudiants de l'ue vs
cul qui reviennent sur les bancs de la
fac lundi prochain en attendant la
semaine dernière l établissement et
cueillette aversa et l'université d'été
de la cpu
la conférence des présidents
d'université première fois que cet
événement se délocalise hors de paris
avec c'est une tradition le discours de
rentrée de la ministre frédéric vidal
pendant deux jours échanges entre les
participants sur le thème cette année de
l'internaute et l'internationalisation
des universités présence d'ailleurs deux
présidents d'établissements catalan et
canadien
quel rôle doivent jouer les universités
françaises dans l'économie mondiale
comment aller vers plus de coopération
étrangère quelques-unes des questions
abordées écouter ses propos on avait
émergé ces dernières années
ce sont des pays voire des continents
entiers qui ont énormément investi dans
le développement de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche dans leur
pays
et ce qui est important c'est que nous
puissions aujourd'hui mettre l'ensemble
de nos établissements aux standards
internationaux de ce qui correspond aux
attentes des étudiants en mobilité
globalement l'enseignement supérieur
recherche et est international mais
c'est vrai que depuis quelques années
les indicateurs comme le classement de
shanghai qui a sorti un peu de temps en
août montrent que cette compétition les
enjeux sont internationaux et donc
chaque établissement doit se positionner
dans ce dans cet espace international
l'internationalisation thématiques aussi
pleinement en lien avec le futur de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines son président était à notre
micro l'université versailles saint
quentin est membre ni rc paris saclay
que nous allons l'intégrer pleinement et
entièrement 2025 et donc à projette
actuaires ces projets paris-saclay c'est
de construire une université à
rayonnement international pour la
recherche et la formation
donc ça c'est ce qui c'est un projet qui
série tout à fait dans cette logique
d'internationalisation à versailles
toujours un défenseur de la chasse à
courre condamné hier par le tribunal
correctionnel il a été reconnu coupable
de violences avec arme contre un
militant de l'association ava
rambouillet les faits remontent au 29
janvier dernier venu filmer une partie
de chasse à courre les membres du
collectif qui demande l'abolition de la
vénerie avait été prise à partie les
propos sont recueillis par aurélie rose
l'homme s'est approché vers moi il l'a
regardé ce qui se passait autour de lui
il
il m'a il m'a visé à trois reprises il a
envoyé de la bombe lacrymogène et s'est
enfui voilà les violences des suiveurs
de chasse à courre se sont multipliés
lors de la dernière saison il faut
absolument cela cesse le prévenu a écopé
d'une peine de deux mois de prison avec
sursis une amende de 1500 euros pour
préjudices physiques et moraux malgré
nos sollicitations il n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions
près de trois ans maintenant qu'a émergé
dans les yvelines ce que l'on appelle
communément la mer des déchets une
décharge sauvage présente sur la commune
de carrières sous poissy est mais aussi
de triel sur seine et à
chanteloup-les-vignes plusieurs
associations militent pour le
nettoiement de cette plaine où a été
déposée où ont été déposés illégalement
à 30 mille mètres cubes de déchets où en
est-on concrètement aujourd'hui on en
parle avec vous antonier froid bonsoir
vous êtes le président de l'association
arrive de seine nature environnement
également conseiller municipal
d'opposition est de la commune de
carrières sous poissy alors dans un
communiqué que vous avez fait apparaître
fin août vous affirmer que rien n'a
bougé depuis plus de deux ans deux ans
et demi exactement sur sur ce sujet de
la décharge sauvage pourquoi vous faites
ce constat écoutez ça fait trois ans
qu'elle est apparue cette décharge est
malheureusement aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune opération de dépollution qui a
été engagée ni même programme et donc on
peut s'interroger justement sur la
réactivité des services de l'état qui à
mon avis est pas au niveau aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la catastrophe écologique
que représente 7,7 des charges qui on
peut noter aussi que du côté du préfet
des yvelines
aucune étude des sols ou deux
on était diligentée auprès de la rs ou
de la drieu de façon à savoir quel est
réellement l'impact sanitaire et
écologique de cette décharge est visé
directement la préfecture des yvelines
vous envisagez une procédure pour
carence fautive de l'état auprès du
tribunal administratif ça c'est en
réflexion on a écouté oui complètement
avec notre avocat puisque il faut quand
même se rendre compte que cette décharge
s'est constitué à l'est en un an à peu
près nous dès qu'on en ait connaissance
on a apporté à la connaissance justement
des autorités cette problématique est
malheureusement en un an rien n'a bougé
si bien que pendant cette année le
volume de déchets a plus que doublé
donc on peut s'interroger justement sur
cet apparent passivité des autorités qui
en tout cas on semblait faciliter la
commission des infractions dans cette
décharge alors nous avons contacté bien
sûr aussi à ce sujet le maire de
carrières sous poissy nous indiquer
qu'un diagnostic a été effectué par la
communauté grand paris seine et oise est
une société spécialisée pour mesurer
toute l'ampleur du problème chiffres y
aussi le montant du nettoiement de la
décharge c'est marylène iapichino qui
l'interrogé dans l'année 2019 on a mis
en place donc un comité de pilotage pour
l'ensemble de ces institutionnels parce
qu'on a raison département nature
viennent qui est présidé par le préfet
visite la communauté urbaine grand paris
seine et oise a défini d'intérêt
communautaire l'ensemble de la plaine
parce que bien sûr le nettoiement des
déchets et le projet environnemental
après il ne peut pas être limité à la
seule commune de carrières sous poissy
au seul territoire communal
il faut que ce projet là il concerne
toute l'année des trois communes ont
parlé dans un un chiffre cette étude
chiffre à 3 millions d'euros le total
pour dépolluer cette décharge de
carrières sous poissy on précise aussi
un que ce sujet a fait
fait une double page dans le dernier
numéro du magazine de carrières sous
poissy voilà que l'on voit à l'écran
le maire de carrière christophe delrieu
parler d'un projet un qui se veut plus
global pour le nettoiement il parle
aussi de redynamiser cette plaine de
carrières sous poissy
c'est un projet qui ne va pas dans le
bon sens selon nous ça va pas dans le
bon sens si vous voulez puisque
aujourd'hui à une urgence qui est
sanitaire et environnementale à d'épaulé
cette décharge elle ne peut pas si vous
voulez cette urgence accepter que la
dépollution se fasse sous condition d'un
nouveau projet et c'est ça aujourd'hui
qui expliquerait ce delrieu c'est qu'il
faut déjà trouver un projet pour
commencer la dépollution du site
nous on pense qu'il faut déjà commencer
la dépollution du site c'est à dire
mettre en sécurité les habitants qui
vivent à 300 mètres de cette décharge
quand il ya des matériaux dangereux club
de l'amiante et mettre en sécurité
également l'environnement puisqu'on
alana pluviales qui se trouve à 5 ou 6
mètres en profondeur du site
évidemment on peut imaginer qu'ils aient
des matériaux polluants des liquides
polluants qui s'infiltrent dans la nappe
alluviale frelons ou une urgence
sanitaire
il ya une urgence à dépolluer en fuite
évidemment on est tous prêts soit autour
de la table pour redonner une vocation
agricole à ce territoire qui depuis les
années 2000 en fait est un petit peu
laissé à l'abandon par les élus donc il
ya vingt ans c'était le moment de
trouver des projets pour cette plaine
aujourd'hui le moment c'est de dépôt lui
cette décharge alors vous avez déposé
une plainte en avril 2018 une enquête a
été bien sûr ouvert pour trouver les
responsables ceux qui ont déchargé
illégalement leurs déchets sur ce
terrain vous avez aussi de votre codé
mener votre propre banque propre enquête
malgré un arrêté municipal qui interdit
l'accès à certains endroits de la
décharge pourquoi cette cette démarche
de mener aussi une enquête bon écoutez
nous on trouve que ça n'avançait pas
suffisamment au niveau administratif
mais également au niveau judiciaire
c'est pour ça que on était d'ailleurs
les premiers à déposer plainte dans ce
dossier ce qui est quand même surprenant
que la communauté urbaine qui est la
première à parité dans ce ciel n'est pas
fait la commune de casse possible n'a
pas fait non plus donc on a décidé de
déposer une plainte devant le procureur
de la république et on s'est dit que la
meilleure façon de cette plainte avance
rapidement
c'était entre guillemets d'investiguer
de notre côté et de transmettre en temps
réel toutes les informations qu'on
arrivait à récolter aux services de
police et vivait d'ailleurs trouvé sur
place des déchets de trois entreprises
qui proviendraient de trois entreprises
opus on agit
si fier une quarantaine de chantiers sur
paris et la petite couronne
ensuite une fois qu'on identifie le
producteur de déchets notre démarche a
été de savoir qui était en charge des
déchets effectivement à des moments en
bloc sur certaines entreprises qui
voient là qui qui me dit la vérité est
ce que c'est l'entreprise qui était
chargée du traitement des déchets ou
est-ce que c'est l'entreprise qui était
détentrice des déchets initialement ça
c'est pas à nous de fabrice fons aux
enquêteurs et on n'est pas des juges on
n'est pas là pour dire c'est cette
entreprise où celle ci en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que les déchets ça
vous embête propriétaires connaissent
une entreprise il vous appartient de vue
d'assurer leur suivi leur traçabilité du
moment où vous le l'évacuer jusqu'au
moment où il se retrouve dans un centre
de retraitement et en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que
certaines entreprises étaient très
limpide dans leur fonctionnement
alors l'une des entreprises concernées
est basée dans le 93 nous l'avons
contacté par mail sa réponse elle nous
ne comprenons pas pourquoi notre société
est impliquée des prospectus ont pu être
déposée par n'importe qui nous n'avions
aucunement connaissance d'une décharge
sauvage dans le 78 l'ensemble de nos
déchets sont évacués en décharge
spécialisés avec bon suivi et dès lors
que le vent est remis à notre chauffeur
nous ne sommes plus responsable de la
traçabilité des déchets une réaction sur
la sur cette réponse nous est
responsable si vous voulez quand vous
prenez la possession d'un déchet vous en
êtes responsable en l'occurrence là ce
sont des prestataires ces gens là ce
sont des gens qui font de la démolition
de bâtiments nous on a réussi à
identifier dans le chantier différents
documents qui nous ont ramené une
entreprise cette entreprise nous
explique finalement que l'immeuble dans
lequel elle était installée a été démoli
dans le cas d'un projet immobilier et
coup de chance pour nous le directeur
cette entreprise à l'époque et pris des
photos des entreprises qui intervenaient
et donc on a pu identifier les sociétés
qui étaient là pour évacuer les déchets
voilà bon on précise d'ailleurs que les
autres entreprises n'ont pas répondu à
notre sollicitation une dernière
question est ce qu'on arrive à la à la
fin de cet entretien est ce que ce
problème à la décharge de carrières sous
poissy n'est pas significative d'un
problème plus global en france avec on
le pense forcément la mort du maire de
signes cet été il faudrait pas faire
davantage de prévention pour que au
final il n'y a pas de de deux décharges
sauvages qu'il n'y a pas d'entreprise de
la prévention mais peut-être qu'il est
chargé
deschênes regarder ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en termes législatifs
puisque brune poirson le secrétaire
d'état à l'écologie a présenté un texte
de la loi anti gaspillage justement qui
prévoit que dans le coup de vent des
matériaux de construction qu'ils soient
intégrés
le coût de leur traitement et c'est une
mesure qui nous semble être
indispensable pour que des filières
puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est bien ça le
problème c'est que les filières de
distribution de matériaux de bâtiments
qui ont normalement l'obligation de
mettre en place des points de collecte
ne sont pas en conformité avec le décret
existants et je pense que cette loi anti
gaspillage d'eau si elle est bien
appliquée améliorer la situation
mais aujourd'hui et je tiens vraiment le
dire écrit reçues précise qui est
urgente c'est de définir quelle est
l'incidence environnementale et
sanitaire de cette décharge mais j'en
appelle encore une fois préfet des
yvelines pour qu'ils saisissent la drieu
et la rs puisque c'est lui qui est
compétent dans ce domaine et on précise
qu'une opération de nettoyage citoyen un
poids de complet sur ce sujet sera
organisé le 21 septembre prochain à
carrières sous poissy à l'occasion du
world cleanapp day merci anthony est
loin d'être passée sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
rives de seine nature environnement
obtenir une place en crèche une
problématique pour certains parents des
attributions qui peuvent aussi laisser
place à une forme de suspicion en
novembre 2018
l'association des maires de france
imagine un vade-mecum dix orientations
pour améliorer les relations entre élus
et administrés une charte qui a choisi
de signer est la semaine dernière la
ville de guyancourt le reportage de
mélanie poker elles sont parfois jugées
suspicieuse les attributions de places
en crèche
l association des maires de france a
choisi de créer une charte pour
accompagner les élus et faciliter les
échanges signé par guyancourt les 29
août dernier la commune propose près de
400 berceau pour l'instant très
honnêtement ça nous a permis de
réfléchir quand même sur la façon
d'améliorer nos pratiques alors des
choses qui peuvent paraître très
anecdotique mais par exemple on a mis en
place depuis notre décision de signer
cette charte de dresser par exemple un
procès verbal à la suite de chaque
commission une signature à la demande
des communes le texte a été pensé autour
de dix orientations les communes
s'engagent à faciliter les démarches
d'inscription et à ajuster lés critères
au fil du temps à partir du moment où
une famille vient
voir le mec cool adjointe au maire
oulhadj en mai jusqu'au moment où on va
lui dire la madame vous avez une place
au madame vous n'avez pas de place donc
celui il ya trois étapes dans
l'attribution il y a le rendez vous avec
les familles très important le premier
vit ensuite la commission d'attribution
qui se réunit qui va statuer et il y a
près le retour que l'on fait aux femmes
la petite enfance n'est pas une
compétence obligatoire pour les villes
si commune yvelinoise ont déjà signé
cette charte
guyancourt rejoint notamment versailles
malheureusement les vacances sont
terminées mais c'est le moment en tout
cas de faire un premier bilan de
l'activité touristique dans la région
ile de france et pour parler de ce sujet
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir c'est la
rédaction de tv 78 ce que le bilan est
positif pour la région ile de france
plutôt oui la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse a annoncé
fin août à paris le bilan touristique
sur le premier semestre la période
estivale dans la région secteur a
enregistré 17 3 millions d'arrivées
hôtelière un chiffre stable par rapport
à l'année dernière une baisse de 3% a
quand même été enregistré en grande
couronne en écoute la présidente de la
région ile de france
nous avions un premier trimestre qui
était inquiétant avec une double
contrainte les mouvements des gilet
jaune dont les images avaient fait le
tour du monde et par ailleurs le break
site de handicap cette année que nous
avons réussi à surmonter que nous avons
réussi à surmonter en ciblant un certain
nombre
deux pays et de public que nous avons
réussi à attirer à paris alors les
italiens les espagnols les américains
les japonais
et puis les français au total mais 4
millions de français sont venus sur la
région sur cette période
trente mille de plus par rapport à 2018
la clientèle internationale représente
7,9 millions de visiteurs bon michael
j'ai ma petite idée mais quel est le
site qui a attiré plus dans les yvelines
dans les yvelines ce n'est pas une
surprise c'est le château de versailles
qui a réalisé les meilleurs chiffres
dans le département 4 millions de
visiteurs sont venus voir le site
une hausse de 6 4% qui place le domaine
juste derrière le louvre mais la
présidente de la région ile de france
pense que le tourisme dans les yvelines
a encore une marge de progression dans
les yvelines on a la possibilité de
développer une offre touristique
colossal autour de toutes nos maisons
des illustres nous avons un certain
nombre de châteaux aussi qui sont
magnifiques je pense à breteuil je pense
à rambouillet je pense à dampierre je
pense à mauves hier on a toute une série
deux musées de parc naturel aussi ce que
le tourisme ce n'est pas que du musée
c'est aussi la nature avec le vexin avec
la vallée de chevreuse donc je pense
qu'on peut développer beaucoup plus
l'activité touristique estivale pourrait
connaître une très belle arrière saison
les perspectives d'un mois de septembre
ensoleillé à pourrait encore booster les
chiffres selon 71 % à des professionnels
du tourisme c'est en sera bon voire très
bon dégrèvement regardera cela avec
attention merci michael pour cette
chronique le sport et du baseball avec
une première à montigny le bretonneux un
match international était organisé le 29
août au stade jean maréchal rencontre
dans le cadre d'un tournoi amical entre
la france et le japon
la sélection nippone était composée de
joueurs de ligue industriels cette
rencontre a attiré à plus d'une centaine
de spectateurs dans les tribunes on
écoute les réactions à votre micro
michael et demi d'euros
en tant que représentant japonais nous
voulons bien figurer sur le terrain pour
remporter ce match et faire honneur à la
sélection de notre pays
pour moi le but aujourd'hui de gagner
mais surtout de représenter fièrement
l'équipe japonaise
il faut être au top tous les jours c'est
très très rare de les avoir c'est vrai
en france
voyage déjà un fou qui se déplace et on
les a déjà eu il ya deux trois ans et
c'est vrai que c'est très rare qui
viennent et c'est vraiment exceptionnel
de les avoir en français et pour
l'anecdote les japonais favori de la
rencontre l'ont facilement emporté sur
le score de 22 à 0 précisons que le
baseball est le sport numéro un dans ce
pays asiatique
mon avis tu es mon invité à présent et
champion du monde c'est francois marne à
bonsoir bonsoir
alors on vous connaît plus communément
sous le nom de francs quoi ça c'est pour
la scène urbaine la scène hip hop fin
août à amsterdam aux pays-bas vous avez
été sacré champion du monde et de house
dance lors du festival summer dance for
ever première question ça fait quoi tout
simplement d'être champion du monde
bah c'est la deuxième fois j'ai fui
enfin c'est pas la chance parce que
c'est du travail c'est et ccd année 2
le sacrifice des bonnes choses mais
c'est vrai que ça fait toujours le même
effet de on n'en revient pas en fait
n'en revient pas on est sur un nuage
pendant un moment fin d'un pendant très
longtemps parce que c'est vraiment des
compétitions que que beaucoup de monde
aimerait rêverait de gagner donc
honnêtement c'est un amour incroyable
là où usain juste pour préciser c'est
une variante du hip hop c'est quelles
sont les spécificités ardennes c'est pas
une danse qui fait partie de la de la
danse hip hop n'a comme aujourd'hui dans
les battles comment dire on est on y
rencontre souvent d'une comme l'autre
dans la même discipline
maintenant la rose and silence qui est
né aux etats-unis dans ces sur ce qu'on
appelle de la house music des rythme
assez rapide sur un bm qui est de 125
donc beaucoup plus rapide que la
technique hip hop mais en général voilà
dans des événements comme celui que j'ai
gagné ou d'autres comme le juste debout
ceux qui connaissent ben on va y
retrouver ces disciplines danse voilà
juste pour préciser vous parliez d'un
rêve le summer dance for ever quelle
place il a dans le milieu de la scène
urbaine est ce que c'est l'un des grands
événements le plus grand événement
peut-être aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment on
veut dire que c'est le plus grand
événement en terme de niveau c'est
vraiment l'événement le plus le plus
grand et le plus difficile à gagner dans
notre discipline en tout cas voilà il a
d'autres bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
celui ci aujourd'hui mince et le sait la
réunion du monde entier voilà il y avait
plus de 180 nationalités d'accord dans
l'événement donc honnêtement cet
événement un saint homme qui se passe
tous les ans au mois d'août
c'est vraiment lui un des plus attendus
en tout cas dans ce milieu mais au final
vous avez été opposé à nenê une
américaine venue de new york
racontez-nous ça a été difficile je
crois qu'il ya eu 15 pages 15 passage
par mon chacun haute pour vous
départager au total au sein d'un
événement il ya eu 15 passé d'accord
voilà après cette finale il ya eu quatre
passages ok maintenant voilà c'est comme
on dire mais on rencontre différents
styles la preuve par exemple nenê que je
respecte énormément qui se connaît
depuis assez longtemps à travers les
vidéos mais c'est la première fois qu'on
se rencontre en compétition et très
honnêtement c'était un échange très
enrichissant après voilà la décision un
moment donné ne dépend plus de nous
mieux contre un on y va on y va à fond
on essayait de donner tout ce qu'on peut
et puis ensuite dans la le résultat
comme j'ai dit ne dépasse pas ne dépend
pas forcément nous donc voilà l'un ou
l'autre c'était mérité pour moi nom
maintenant c'est moi qui ai gagné
c'était incroyable et puis voilà ça
aurait pu être elle aussi leaf insectes
incroyable pour elle aussi donc ça reste
une très très bonne expérience et à quoi
vous aura se ressemblent et du coup les
prochains mois pour vous est ce que vous
avez participé à d'autres événements
qualité en sa qualité de champion du
monde alors je pars en argentine dès
demain voilà pour un événement une
question enfin il ya pas mal
d'événements que je fais à pas mal de
deux voyages etc
mais après de mon côté je suis beaucoup
plus basé dans ma ville pendant que la
jolie on a fini issu du val fourré je
suis vraiment dans une certaines
transmissions et sa gelée depuis mon
plus jeune âge parce que je si j'ai
gagné cette compétition c'est grâce à
une seule et unique personne qui
s'appelle cap et là c'est mon frère
voilà non mais qu'il voulait remporter
juste debout le sact en 2016
exactement égal mais aussi cet
événement-là des années avant le summer
dance for ever donc c'est juste comment
dire une suite logique
c'est un peu de famille donc voilà on a
bien su beaucoup plus dans la
transmission avec mon association start
stop à mantes la jolie
donc on fait des coûts lourds ont essayé
de transmettre aux plus jeunes pour que
ça fasse une chaîne continue alors vous
parlez de cette victoire a juste debout
en 2007 vous avez été aussi désigné
champion de france de bréteil breakdance
pardon lors du bboy france
là les les prochains mois pour vous ils
vont ressembler à quoi est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres compétitions pour vous on a
peut-être dans un coin de sa tête les jo
il y aura le breakdance audio est ce que
ça fait partie de vos objectifs pas du
tout non parce que c'est pas la même
discipline aux jo de 2024 à paris où
exactement mais c'est pas la même
discipline
évidemment dans la house dance voir là
dedans la house dance et puis après je
suis allé très près parce que ça fait
partie de notre culture
mais là les prochains mois on fait ça
sera vraiment la concentration sur mon
association nos événements et puis met
en parallèle évidemment les voyages les
les
les cours enfin tout ce qui est autour
de ces milieux moment il ya pour moi
enfin deuxième fois sacré champion du
monde c'est vraiment énorme mais il n'y
aura pas un énorme changement parce que
voilà j'ai des objectifs bien précis
après leurs trois opportunités qui vont
se présenter grâce à cette victoire
mais voilà l'idée pour moi c'est
vraiment de me focaliser sur cette
transmission faire évoluer les miens
comme moi j'étais évolué grâce à nous
faire bravo en tout cas franck quoi pour
ce titre de champion du monde je précise
qu'on peut aussi suivre votre actualité
sur votre instagram qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran un mot de vélo pour refermer
ce journal le département a accueilli la
19e édition du à paris brest paris cet
été un rendez-vous cyclotouriste
organisée tous les 4 ans et des milliers
de sportifs venus de 66 pays se sont
élancés à la bergerie nationale de la
bergerie nationale dans le parc du
château de rambouillet ils ont traversé
cinq régions et 180 une commune
on écoute l'un des organisateurs au
micro de gwenaëlle saintilan en terme de
fréquentation
un niveau de participation jamais connu
cette année un 6674 participants 534
femmes 66 pays représentés c'est tout
juste exceptionnel un petit un petit
aménagement a fait on avait
malheureusement que 22 % de français ce
qui ce qui
fausse et c'est un chiffre un peu bas
pour une telle randonnée sur le
territoire français est la fin du set 8
journal merci de l'avoir suivi et belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]